مدد محتجون في تونس بتصريحات الرئيس قيس
سعيد بشان المهاجرين الافارقه واعتبروها
تكريسا لخطاب الكراهيه الشعبويه وكان
الاتحاد الافريقي قد دانت تلك التصريحات
ووصفها بانها خطاب كراهيه ذو طابع عنصري
ضد الافارقه في بلاده يتزامر هذا مع تزايد
الانتقادات الدوليه لحمله الاعتقالات
المستمره في تونس واخرها
الامم المتحده
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دلاله تزايد
الادانات الدوليه لحمله الاعتقالات وسط
المعارضين في تونس واتساع دائره القلق
الدولي والاقليمي من مواقف الرئيس واخرها
انتقاد الاتحاد الافريقي لها وما مغزى
توسع حمله الاعتقالات في تونس بالتزامن مع
هذه الانتقادات وما واجهته تبريرات الرئيس
لتصريحاته التي اعتبرها الاتحاد خطاب
كراهيه ذات طبيعه عنصريه وما فرص نجاح
المواقف الدوليه الاخيره وما قد ينبني
عليها من ضغوط في دفع السلطات التونسيه
للجلوس مع معارضها وايجاد مخرج من الازمه
السياسيه والاقتصاديه الراهنه في البلاد
[موسيقى]
في خضم حمله اعتقالات تتسع يوما بعد يوم
في اوساط معارضي الرئيس قيس سعيد في تونس
ووسطى موجه انتقادات وتحركات واحتجاجات
قانونيه وسياسيه ونقابيه ضد السياسات
الرئيس دخل على خطها الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل الذي اكد ان البلاد دخلت
مرحله الخطر وانه لن يقبل الاستبداد
وسيواجهه من افريقيا جنوب الصحراء انتقدت
داخليه وخارجيه من نوع اخر لسياساته
ومواقفه فقد نظم محتجون في تونس مظاهره
نددت بما سمته الخطاب الرسمي العنصريه ضد
هؤلاء المهاجرين واعتبر تصريحات قيس
السعيد بشانهم تكريسا لما سمته الخطاب
العنصريه الشعبويه في تونس
خارجيا جاءت الانتقادات لتصريحات سعيد
بخصوص المهاجرين الافارقه من مفوضيه
الاتحاد الافريقيه التي قالت انها تدين
بشده تلك التصريحات ووصفتها بالعنصريه
وبانها تتعارض مع رساله وروحي ومبادئ
الاتحاد الافريقي واضافت المفوضيه في بيان
انها ابلغت ممثله تونس بما سمته صدمه
المفوضيه وقلقها من استهداف مواطنين
افارقه بغض النظر عن وضعهم القانوني في
البلاد وكان الرئيس قيس سعيد طالبه بضروره
المصارعه الى وضع حد للتدفق اعداد كبيره
من المهاجرين غير النظاميين من افريقيا
جنوب الصحراء الى بلده واصفا تدفقهم بانه
مؤامره لتغيير التركيبه الديموغرافيه في
البلاد واعتبرهم مصدر عنف وجرائم وممارسات
غير مقبوله على حد قوله
انتقادات تضاف الى اخرى تتعلق هذه المره
بحمله الاعتقالات ضد معارضي الرئيس قيس
سعيد ابتدرتها واشنطن وجاء اخرها من باريس
التي اعربت عن قلقها من تلك الاعتقالات
وقد دعت الخارجيه الفرنسيه السلطات
التونسيه الى ضمان احترام الحريات
وطالبتها بالحفاظ على الانجازات
الديمقراطيه في البلاد الامم المتحده
اعربت بدورها عن قلقها من التطورات
الاخيره في تونس لا سيما حمله الاعتقالات
التي وصفتها بالتعسفيه وبانها تقلص
المساحه المتاحه للمجتمع المدني والصحفيين
في البلاد
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من تونس سمير
ديلو المحامي وعضو اللجنه التنفيذيه لجبهه
الخلاص الوطنيه ومن تونس ايضا بالاحسن
الحياوي الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ومن
واشنطن الدكتور دانيال مدير دراسات
الديمقراطيه والحكم في جامعه جورج تاون
ابدا بك لماذا زادت الانتقادات في هذا
التوقيت
للرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد وطريقه حكمه من
دول الغرب بالتحديد اضافه الى ذلك الاتحاد
الافريقي
لقد شاهدنا في الايام العشره الماضيه
ارتفاعا في حمله الاعتقالات ضد المعارضه
السياسيه الشرعيه بالاضافه الى الصحفيين
وهو جهد واضح لمنع اي معارضه سياسيه
لقيس سعيد وايضا الجهود الايه الى بناء
نظام استبدادي وهذا ما تعزز من خلال
تصريحاته المرتبطه بنظريه المؤامره ودور
المهاجرين الافارقه
والدوره يؤدونه في تونس وبالتالي كان هناك
زياده في حمله القمع واعتقد ان الاسره
الدوليه بدات بالرد بطريقه لم تكن موجوده
في السابق سيد بلحسن في رايك كيف ينظر
الى هذه الانتقادات من جانب الرئيس سعيد
ومن يؤيدونه
نعم في الحقيقه نحن الان نتحدث ربما عن
موضوعين مختلفين نتحدث عن موضوع يعني
الهجره لغير الشرعيه للافارقه جنوب
الصحراء ونتحدث ايضا عما يسمى بحمله
الاعتقالات وان كنت افضل يعني استعمال لفظ
الايقافات هناك جمله من العقارات صدرت في
حق مجموعه كبيره من الاشخاص
هذه المجموعه الجزء الاكبر من هذه
المجموعه هم من عرفوا بمعارضتهم سياسيه
للرئيس قيس سعيد والى حد هذه اللحظه وامام
الصمت الجهات الرسميه سواء الجهاد
القضائيه او مثلا وزاره الداخليه هذا
الامر احدث حاله من التوتر بل دعنا نقول
حاره من الهلع خاصه في صفوف الاعلاميين
والحقوقيين ولا يمكن طبعا القبول بهذا
الصوت الرسمي المطلوب الان من رئيس
الجمهوريه او من الجهات الرسميه في تونس
ان توضح ملابسات هذه الايقافات اذا كان
الامر يتعلق بم
الاستاذ سمير ديلو ما الذي تعنيه لكم
زياده الانتقادات للرئيس سعيد من
الجهات الدوليه المختلفه التي ذكرناها من
قبل الامم المتحده
والدول الغربيه والاتحاد الافريقي هذه
المره ايضا
حفظوا اللغه الدبلوماسيه وهي لا تخلق
واقعا تعلق عليه وانما هي تتفاعل مع واقع
ما يجري في تونس منذ اشهر عديده هو تماما
كاسيناريو الحروب بدات بقصف الجوي
بطائرات الليبيه
اصابه المجلس الاعلى للقضاء وكل الهياكل
القضاه لترهيب القضاه
المعارضين من السياسيين بتهمم مضحكه من
قبيله تامر على امن الدوله الداخليه
والخارجي ومحاوله تغيير هيئه الدوله نحن
قلنا للقارئ ماذا بقي في هيئه الدوله لكي
يتم تغييره تونس كانت جمهوريه بها رئيس
جمهوريه وحكومه وبرلمان فاصبحت بلدا
بجمهوريه الرئيس يستحوذ على كامل السلطات
ويتصرف في البلاد تصرف المالكي في ملكه
اليوم تم اصدار ثمانيه بطاقات ايداع
بالسجن بحق مناضلين الشرفاء طيله حياتهم
لم يرتكبوا عنفا ولم يدعوا اليه تهمتهم
الوحيده وجريمتهم الوحيده هي المجاهره
بمعارضه الحكم الفردي وتمسك بالنظام
الديمقراطي ناجي لحق البلاد طيب الرئيس
السعيد الذي رفض مرارا الانتقادات
الخارجيه لسياساته دافع عن حمله
الاعتقالات الجاريه حاليا في البلاد وتوعد
بما سماه فتح الملفات خاصه تلك المتعلقه
بالفساد وبمحاسبه كل من اجرم في حقب حق
الشعب التونسي فيما يخص التصريحاته بشان
المهاجرين الافارقه في تونس سخر سعيد من
اتهامه بالعنصريه بينما اعربت الخارجيه
التونسيه عن استغرابها لتصريحات الاتحاد
الافريقي بشانها واعتبرت موقفه انسياقا
وراء مزايدات واتهامات لجهات ذات اغراض
مختلفه
السيد كيف ينظر دوليا لتصريحات كتلك التي
ادلى بها الرئيس السعيد حول
المهاجرين وانهم جزء من
يعني خطه لتغيير ديموغرافي في تونس كما
انهم يعتبرون
يعني منبعا للاجرام وهو من اتقده الاتحاد
الافريقي هل هذه التصريحات يمكن ان تكون
مقبوله وكما ذكرت الرئيس سعيد سخر من ان
يتهم بالعنصريه
اعتقد ان النظره هي ان الرئيس قيس سعيد
لديه دائما افكار
بخصوصي نظريات المؤامره هذه النظريات
المحبوكه الخطط من قبل المعارضه انها
تتامر ضد الدوله من خلال هؤلاء المهاجرين
ما من ادله ابدا بالنسبه الى هذا الموضوع
وبالتالي هذا
يقود صوره الرئيس لاننا لا نتحدث فقط عن
اجنده ديكتاتوريه ومن الواضح انه يتصرف
باستبداد هذا مما لا شك فيه ولكن هذا
الامر مبني على سلسله من الاكاذيب وكما
قيل في السابق هناك محاوله للتخلص من
النظام القضائي المستقل الذي من شانه ان
يحقق بالجرائم بطريقه قانونيه وديمقراطيه
ويود ان يكون الرئيس
الحكم والقاضي والهيئه التنفيذيه اذا هذا
تصعيد اضافي في مشروع استبدادي ديكتاتوري
ولكن هناك مخاوف متزايده بان نظره الرئيس
بالنسبه الى شمال افريقيا والمنطقه
العربيه الرئيس يؤمن بنظريات المؤامره
ولكن لا اساس لهذه النظريات وهي طريقه
سيئه لاداره شؤون اي دوله نعم هذا من جانب
ولكن سالتك عن اتهامه بالعنصريه هل
تصريحاته يمكن ان ينظر اليها على انها
تصريحات مقبوله
هذه التصريحات هي من الواضح انها عنصريه
من خلال هذه التصريحات الرئيس اضاف مساله
لم تكن موجوده في الصادق وصدم عدد كبيرة
من التونسيين بعض زملاء
اندهشوا بالفعل بهذه التصريحات التي ادلى
بها الرئيس وزاره الخارجيه وزير الخارجيه
يحاول ان يقول ان هذه التصريحات غير
عنصريه ولكن اذا ما سالت المواطن التونسي
العادي
والعشره او 15% من داويه البشره السوداء
من المواطنين التونسيين انا متاكد من انهم
ينظرون الى هذه التصريحات على انها عنصريه
وهذا ما زاد من المخاوف المرتبطه بسلوكي
الرئيس سعيد بشان البلاد زيد بلحسن ما
رايك في تبريرات الرئيس اعيد لهذه
التصريحات التي يعتبرها ضيفنا في سبيل
المثال تصريحات عنصريه وصادمه
في الحقيقه يعني تمت مشكله كبرى ان يتولى
رئيس الجمهوريه الحديث
بصوره عفويه وهو يتحمل المسؤوليه كامله
اذا كان قد اخطا في التعبير ولكن في
الحقيقه يبدو ان هذه التسريحات يعني اول
تاويلا بعيدا جدا لم تكن هناك اي دعوه الى
العنصريه ولن يتم الحديث لا عن جنس ولا عن
لون
الافارقه وبالمناسبه تونس دوله افريقيه
قبل ان تكون شيئا اخر والان اذا كنا نلوم
رئيس الجمهوريه عن الحديث عن المؤامره
الامر ليس مؤامره الامر هو خطه وهذه الخطه
او سياسه ينتهجها الاتحاد الاوروبي تحدث
عنها
البرلماني الاوروبي تحدث عنه انت تقول
لاول تاويلا بعيدا ولكن يعني يلحظ ان
الاتحاد الافريقي على سبيل المثال
اضيف الى قائمه
المنتقدين لسياسه الرئيس قيس السعيد
يعني هو يخسر اكثر دوليا
وبسرعه اذا سمحت الاتحاد الاوروبي يتحدث
عن توسيع حدوده حتى تكون حدوده في الحدود
الجنوبيه للبحر الابيض المتوسط وان تكون
تونس والمغرب اساسا هي منطقه لتوطين
الافارقه من جنوب الصحراء الراغبين
بالهجره الى اوروبا وهذا امر يعني وقع
الحديث فيه اكثر من مره الان ان يذهب رئيس
الجمهوريه لتحديد عن تغيير ديموغرافيه
تونس نعم هذا الامر في الكثير من الشطر
موقف الان
المؤتمر الافريقي يبدو ان التاويلات التي
حدثت على مستوى الاعلام التونسي والتحركات
التي حدثت على المستوى الاعلامي التونسي
والبعض الذي قامت بتاويل كلام رئيس
الجمهوريه وذهب به الى منحى بعيد جدا يعني
الموقف بني على ما قيل على كلام الرئيس
قيس سعيد وليس مباشره على كلام هو الموقف
يعني عشان نكون واضحين هو الموقف كان
اعتراض على كلام الرئيس سعيد وليس على ما
قيل عن كلام الرئيس سعيد ولنسمع راس
الاستاذ
سعيد وليس كلام الرئيس قيس سعيد موقف
الاتحاد الافريقي كان ينتقد كلام ينتقد
كلام الرئيس سعيد ولا ينتقد ما قيل عن
الرئيس سعيد في النهايه هو المسؤول كرئيس
نعم المؤتمر الافريقي بنى موقفه من خلال
الكلام الذي قيل حول ما قاله الرئيس
الحسن ساظل اقول لك هو ساقول يعني لا نريد
ان نستمر في تكرير الامر يعني ولكن نسمع
راي السيد سمير ديلو هل التبريرات مقبوله
لانتقاد الاتحاد الافريقي وهل اولت الامور
لتصريحات يعني لم يكن مقصودا بها اي اي
عنصريه تجاه اي احد
الامر اكثر من ذلك مش قلت نظريات المؤامره
انها في الغالب مبنيه على معطيات مغلوطه
المعطيات التي قدمت في هذه القضيه خاطئه
من مبتداها الى نهايتها الاعداد التي قدمت
للمهاجرين جنوب الصحراء سواء منهم
النظاميين او غير شرعيين هي اعداد المضخمه
جدا وبالاضافه الى ذلك فالحديث عن مؤامره
للتوطين تعود الى بدايه القرن والحديث عن
المبالغ الماليه الباهره التي دفعت
من قبيل الخيال السياسي
الذي قمتم العنف ورد الفعل على
في الحقيقه تونس ليست لذلك
يعيشون في بلدهم منذ سنوات طويله ونحن
افارق ولم تكن هناك اي اشكاليه في التعامل
سواء مع اولئك الذين كانتهم قانونيه او
غيرها وبالمناسبه
التونسيون في اوروبا يعدون بمئات الالاف
وسيعاملون بمثل ما يعامل به الافارقه في
تونس ان ميزنا بين المقيمين بصوره قانونيه
واولئك الذين
ننتبه الى ان اول من رحب بتصريحات
الرئاسيه هو اليمين المتطرف الفرنسي
ايريكزيمون الضغوطات الدوليه سيد برمبرج
هل ستزيد وما تعتقد يعني كيف تعتقد انها
سوف تؤثر على سياسه الرئيس سعيد
وهل يبقى هل بامكانها ان تدفعه الى الجلوس
مع معارضيه وحل هذه الازمات
ايضا لا اعتقد ذلك اعتقد ان لديه مشروع
ايل الى اعاده تشكيل السلطه في تونس وهو
عقد العزب على تحقيق هذا المشروع من خلال
العمل على التحكم بمخاوف
ومشاغل التونسيين بشكل يومي وما رايناه
بالنسبه للاتحاد الافريقي جزء من ذلك
واعتقد ان الاسره الدوليه والولايات
المتحده لديها اهتمام بشان اوكرانيا وهناك
الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا وبالنظر الى
تصريح الصادر عن وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
هناك تردد بالنسبه الى كيفيه التعاطي مع
او ضد القيصر سعيد لاسباب المتعدده بما في
ذلك الاسباب الامنيه وهناك دعم من الخليج
العربي يحظى به ولربما من الجزائر
وبالتالي لا ارى ان المعادله الدوليه من
شانها ان تغير منظور الرئيس على الارجح
لقد عمل على هذه التصريحات من الخارج لكي
يقول ان هذه التصريحات هي جزء من المؤامره
ضد النظام وضد الرئيس وهذه الشعبويه التي
نعم اذا سمحت اذا سمحت لدي دقيقتان واسال
سؤال سيد بن حسن اليحياوي في دقيقه او اقل
اذا سمحت لي كيف يمكن ان تؤثر الضغوطات
الدوليه على سياسته خاصه اذا المعارضين
في الحقيقه ما تدنى من الرئيس قيس سعيد
انه لا يغيروا مواقفه بتاتا وفي مناسبات
اخرى السابقه كانت هناك ضغوط دوليه وكان
هناك حديث من بعضك ودوليه حول ما يحدث في
تونس ولكن الرئيس سعيد مره قدما في تنفيذ
مشروعه وفي تنفيذ تعهداته وبالتالي لا
تصور ان هذه المره سيختلف الامر ما يهمنا
الان وقبل كل شيء وحتى تخف حده التوتر
الموجوده في الداخل التونسي ان تتولى
الجهات الرسميه تقديم مبررات وتبريرات
لايقاف هذا العدد الكبير من السياسيين
التونسيين استاذ سمير ديلو
اتفق مع ضيفك الكريم من تونس السيد قيس
سعيد لا يبالي باي انتقاد ولا يعبا باي
الاف الصفحات لما كانت فيها جمله واحده
تسمح له بان يسمع نصيحه من داخل بلاد او
من خارجه اذا شكرا جزيلا لكم جميعا من
تونس سمير ديل والمحامي وعضو اللجنه
التنفيذيه لجبهه الخلاصه الوطنيه والحسن
يحياوي الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ومن واشنطن
كان معنا الدكتور دانيال مدير ودراسات
الديمقراطيه والحكم في جامعه جورج تاون
مشاهدينا بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر شكرا لكم على حسن المتابعه
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]